COLD MCANLIS: In this episode
of "Cloud Performance Atlas,"
I help some social savants with
their Datastore performance.
Are we still on for
performance game night?
Stay tuned to find out.
FriendSet is building a
standard, run of the mill
mobile social media platform.
However, as their user
loads started to rise,
they noticed that the time it
takes to retrieve social posts
started to get
longer and longer.
After a few hours of profiling
and working with their team,
we quickly saw the issue.
Although their client was only
getting part of the fetch data,
their server was fetching
the full data per entity
from Datastore.
And as the lists got larger,
their performance got worse.
See, by default, Cloud Datastore
will return entire entities
as the result of a query.
And most developers haven't yet
found that projection queries
can actually help them.
We see a lot of implementations
with Datastore store
that looks something like this.
A user makes a
request, and Datastore
fetches the relevant entities.
Then some front end prunes
the entity properties
and passes on only
the relevant data back
to the requesting client.
Sadly, though, this is
a slow way to do things.
I mean, you're fetching
the full entities
and then taking the
time to trim them down.
For those situations
where you might not
need all of the properties
returned from an entity,
projection queries allows
Datastore to return only
what you need rather than
fetching everything and having
to do the culling yourself.
For example, if
you need to access
only the keys from a query
result, use a keys-only query.
This can be really
helpful in situations
where you need to do a keys-only
query first and then fetch
a subset of entities based
on the results from that
rather than executing
a larger general query.
Likewise, using projections,
your query returns
abridged results with only
the specified properties
populated with values.
Once again, since
the query is only
returning a subset of
data, you can end up
in a more performant position.
Now, for FriendSet, we had
to do a few fancier things.
But sadly, we don't have time
to cover all of that here.
Instead, check out the
Datastore Queries page,
where you'll find a whole
list of optimizations
for your queries that can
help in every situation
you might find yourself in.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of the Cloud
Performance Atlas content.
Because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]